Hi, I'm James Chittenden
here, solutions
engineer for Google
Cloud Platform.
Today I'm going to talk about
how to effectively prepare
video assets for
streaming delivery
on Google Cloud Platform.
When preparing media
files for streaming,
there are many options you have
to consider-- from transcoding,
cropping the video files
using Google Compute Engine,
leveraging open source
libraries-- such as ffMpeg,
HandBrake-- or even
leveraging manage offerings,
like Wix media
platform, Zing Coder,
and many other
commercial offerings.
There are many
variables that come
into play that could
interrupt playback,
and a few top ones include the
diverse devices of your users--
are they running on a mobile
device, a desktop, a TV
with a Chromecast?
So you have to account for the
different sizes of screens.
Secondly, users with
varied bandwidth speeds.
You're going to have some users
that have slow connections,
and some of them that are fast.
Thirdly, network traffic from
your streaming video server
has to be blazing fast.
And we're going to cover that
in depth in the next video.
And then lastly, the performance
abilities of the user's device.
Do they have a fast
CPU, or a slow CPU?
The goal is to find the right
balance between bit rate
and resolution, as it relates to
the end user's connection speed
and device ability.
To achieve these goals,
we need to leverage
a technique called
adaptive streaming.
Let's explore this concept.
So what is adaptive streaming?
Well, adaptive
streaming is a technique
of detecting a user's bandwidth
capabilities in real time,
taking that information,
and adjusting
the quality of the video
stream accordingly.
The result is less buffering,
faster start times, and overall
a much better user experience
for both your high speed
and low speed connections.
Adaptive streaming works
by having multiple bit
rates available for the
player or server, on a CDN,
potentially, to pull content
based on the user's connection
speed and ability.
Let's dig into this
concept with an example.
Say I have a large
video that I need
to transcode to
accommodate users
with mobile resolutions
for Android, iOS,
and other mobile devices.
I also want to ensure I have
HD versions of the video that's
formatted for big desktop
screens, as well as TV devices.
So as a user, they
should be able to use
my app on their device
and, unknown to them,
multiple streams
will be available
and will be seamlessly switched
to match their internet
connection as it
degrades or improves.
The key is keep this
process smooth and seamless.
And when using
adaptive streaming,
we can achieve no
interruption to playback.
So check out this diagram.
I have a sample video player
on Google Cloud Platform,
and it might be serving up
multiple formats all at once.
I have a large sample video,
2,612 kilobits per second,
another is 1,600
kilobits per second,
and another 1,200,
and 800, and so on.
The goal is to select the
right encoding profile
to insure each device that's
consuming my video content will
receive the right
format and right
size that's appropriate
for their connection.
Let's explore how we can
prepare our video assets.
When selecting a
transcoding tool
there are several options
available to leverage.
Depending on your preference,
whether you like command line
access for automation,
or simplistic user
interface for manual
conversion, there's
many open source tools that
can be leveraged within Google
Compute Engine to provide an
automated video transcoding
pipeline.
The first is ffMPEG.
This is a popular,
open-source product
that provides an extensive
cross-platform solution
for converting videos
to streaming formats.
This tool supports many
input container formats.
It's a very mature tool,
and it has strong automation
capabilities.
The Nexus HandBrake-- another
open-source cross-platform tool
that you can use to convert
any video from nearly
any format to a selection
of modern, widely
supported codecs.
That's from the
open-source side.
From a managed
perspective, there
are several fully-managed
video processing solutions
that integrate directly
with Google Cloud Platform.
Let's look at a couple of
the popular options that
could Jumpstart
your video solution,
and scale up with
your app's needs.
The first is
Brightcove Zencoder.
This is a cloud-based
transcoding
solution for both live video,
as well as video on demand.
You simply push your
video to the Zencoder API,
and this managed solution
takes care of the rest.
Customers like Funny
or Die, SmugMug
have all built their video
workflows around ZenCoder
to encode large volumes of
video affordably and quickly.
So this same powerful tool
set is available for you
as a developer.
The next is Wix media platform.
Another collection
of services that
allows you to store,
serve, upload, and manage
images, audio, and video files.
This platform allows you
to host, transcode, answer
video seamlessly across any
internet-enabled device.
If you want to take the work out
of standing up your own video
encoding solution,
these managed services
are definitely the way to go.
As a quick recap,
it's very important
to spend some time
thinking through what
your primary objectives are
for streaming video content,
from your app to
your target users.
You need to think about which
options fit your app's needs.
As you can see, there
are many options
to leverage on Google
Cloud Platform,
from open source tools, to
fully managed, third party video
processing solutions.
For more information,
please see the links below,
and stick around.
Watch the next
video to learn more
about how to
effectively serve up
your newly encoded video content
using Google Cloud Platform.
That's it for now.
The next step is delivering
these video assets
in a blazing fast way.
This is James
Chittenden with Google,
and we will see you on the next
episode of Launchpad Online.
[MUSIC PLAYING]